hey guys so this is the last of the
series how to make your shots more
filmic
this is the before this is the after
uh it was shot at sunset iso 100 150th
of a second
super slow shutter so i wanted to get a
little bit of motion
because she was flipping her hair
and i went to i wanted to capture more
of a dreamy look so let's get into it
okay
what i'm gonna do
bring the brightness just a little bit
up
exposure a little bit down
so difference between exposure and
brightness is that
brightness will kind of bring
will affect the whole image so we'll
bring
all the details up in the shadows in the
mid tones and the highlights but mostly
highlights
uh while the brightness will mostly
affect the mid tones okay so it's a lot
softer
good um i can bring the brightness a
little bit up conscious a little bit
down
shadows just a little bit uh down
white point down and maybe a little bit
more of that black
down
so we add more contrast
cool okay
i i really want to like put uh
focus in their eyes that's why i'm
bringing down the blacks
so it's a little bit
darker
cool
exposure just a little bit up
good
i think it's moody enough now
maybe i'll just bring up the luma to
give a little bit more kick in the
highlights around here these are
actually not highlights if we look in
the curve
you can see by hovering over the image
where that area is positioned in the
curve section so
highlights should be somewhere around
here we have no highlights actually
these are mid-tones
but because the whole image is kind of
like dark and moody compared to the the
darkest points this seems to be the
highlights
so let's bring some green in the
highlights as you can see that makes a
whole lot of difference
and maybe some blue
in the mid tones
um some
[Music]
some magenta in the
shadows
and
that's pretty much it but one thing i
want to do is maybe add more green
around here
also maybe make her
skin tone
more yellow cool so let's go into color
editor press the three dots as we can
see
the red channel is is controlling uh
most of the colors around here so that's
what i'm looking for actually maybe a
little bit of orange as well
so what i want to do is just add more
more green let's say to that part just
like so so i don't think i will be
needing this anymore yeah
this is the before this is after
super fast super simple
let's add some grain silver rich grain
let's zoom in a little bit
yeah i think that's pretty much
a little bit more
cool
[Music]
okay so this is pretty much it
as i promised i will export each of
these looks as presets and leave them in
a link below for you to download
one thing to notice though is that no
presets will work for all photos
meaning that each image has different
colors and is shot at different
exposures
so what i will do besides the preset
name i will include exposure level
they're supposed to be taken at and the
kind of light they have been shot at
and this way it will be easier for you
to choose the right preset for your
photos
i hope you enjoyed this short series and
let me know in the comments if you want
to see more of these to come out or if
you if you're interested in more
in-depth color grading
uh for example how to choose the colors
how to analyze the shot and uh to get
the mood that you want
don't forget to subscribe like and
follow me on social media if you're
interested in my latest projects
see ya